bonjour à toutes et à tous ici votre art
go rock nationale enfin nous avons un
premier aperçu de ce que pourrait être
star wars 9 le dernier opus de cette
nouvelle trilogie prévue pour milieu
décembre 2019
je préfère vous prévenir dès maintenant
cette analyse est totalement personnelle
et n'engage que mon avis vous allez voir
du subjectif pur et dur il se peut que
vous ne soyez pas d'accord avec moi ou
que je ne trompe donc ne vous inquiétez
pas bref n'hésite pas à lâcher ton plus
gros pouce bleus pour enfin le retour de
star wars
voyons ce que le trailer a dans le
ventre je pensais à la base vous faire
un trois théories comme à l'ancienne ça
me rappelait de nombreux souvenirs
d'ailleurs mais je pense qu une simple
analyse serait plus approprié bien je ne
vais pas analyser plan par plan je n'y
vois pas grand intérêt en revanche je
vais vous dire ce que je ressens ce que
je comprends et ce que je pense être
légitime pour la fin de la saga
nous démarrons sur une ré plus
déterminés et puissante que jamais l'udc
semble avoir fini d'enseignés arrête
tout ce qu'elle devait savoir pour
devenir la dernière jedi comme lui avait
demandé yoda dans l'épisode 8
il est clair que rien n'est surprenant
pour le moment nous savons déjà depuis
un moment que mark hamill l'acteur de
l'udc serait de retour dans star wars 9
et ce dernier est le mentionnait même
déjà dans le huitième film luc reviendra
très certainement en force
ghost comme yoda ou obi-wan auparavant
et enseignera à la voie des jedi arrêt
le monologue de l'udc en font le
souligner nous avons transmis notre
savoir mille générations vivent toi
cette phrase souligne énormément le fait
que ray est bel et bien la dernière j'ai
des existantes dans l'univers elle a
suivi le même chemin le même
apprentissage grâce à luc la phrase mais
c'est ton combat veut dire énormément de
choses pour moi
effectivement cela rey a le pouvoir de
défaire caille lorraine néanmoins battre
caille lorraine ne relève pas le fait
que c'est le combat de ré car il est
également celui de la résistance et même
de tous les peuples opprimés luc mans
sonne bien que c'est
ton combat ce qui implique des raisons
personnelles à tout ça et je pense que
vous savez de quoi je parle
ray souffre de ne pas connaître ses
origines et c'est un mystère qui plane
depuis l'opus 7
il est évident que l'épisode 9 nous
apportera des réponses à ce sujet et je
pense que le trailer on a déjà beaucoup
dévoilé qu'est ce qui me fait penser
ceci je vous en ai déjà parlé plusieurs
fois en vidéo mais il est clair que pour
moi on connaît toujours pas l'identité
des parents de ré c'est trop simple
c'est trop mal à mener bref caille
lorraine a menti dans l'épisode 8
si nous nous penchons sur le titre de ce
neuvième opus qui est the rise of
skywalker que nous pouvons traduire par
la remontée en gros des skywalker la
renaissance l'élève mans bref nous
comprenons facilement que l'histoire des
skywalker n'est pas prête de s'arrêter
et qu'au contraire elle va monter en
intensité
ray semble être en quête de quelque
chose une mission qui semble personnel
this is your fight
nous la retrouvons sur une planète
déserte qui semble être tatouine mais je
n'en suis pas très sûr peu importe que
ce soit de jacou ou tatouine il y à un
rapprochement direct avec soin les
skywalker soir est elle même donc un
retour sur des origines pour avoir des
réponses plus aucun skywalker n'existe à
ce jour à parquet et lorraine mais je
souligne le fait que ben est nommé en
tant que ben solo principalement bien
que le sang des skywalker coule dans ses
veines
le nom skywalker est associé aux jedi et
aux biens dans cette nouvelle trilogie
l'udc est toujours surnommé skywalker
donc si ce titre parle bien de kayes
lorraine cela sous-entendrait un retour
vers le côté lumineux mais
c'est un petit peu tiré par les cheveux
the rise of skywalker la renaissance des
skywalker soit une montée en puissance
essayez de réfléchir à quel personnage
monte en puissance constamment et va
même terminé sa formation aurait
évidemment le trailer indique clairement
pour moi que ray possède un
rapprochement énorme avec et skywalker
et qu'elle pourrait même descendre de
cette lignée on ne sait comment ça
risque de ne pas plaire à certains mais
c'est du moins ce que moi je ressens en
regardant cette bande annonce
pour continuer il faut que nous parlions
du retour de palpatine soit dark sidious
un retour plus que surprenant est que je
n'arrive pas à comprendre je ne jugerai
pas les choix de jj abrams par rapport à
ceux ci mais analysons du coup ce retour
proposée dans le trailer le trailer se
termine sur le rire de palpatine
c'est même un fait et jj abrams a bel et
bien confirmé son retour dans star wars
donc nous sommes réellement sur une
information concrète pour commencer
l'argumentation luc mentionne arrêt nous
serons toujours à tes côtés
cette phrase prouve effectivement le
retour de luke en force ghost mais le
fait qu'ils soient plusieurs via
l'utilisation du pronom nous perturbe
grandement
est ce que l'udc parle de lui même
accompagné de yoda qui avait déjà fait
un retour dans l'opus suite très
certainement
ou bien est-ce qu'obi wan seraient
potentiellement aussi de retour en tant
que force ghost pour ceux qui l'auraient
oublié la voix d'obi wan est présente
dans la vision aurait une vision qui
s'étend sur les trois opus de la saga se
serait possiblement un retour légitime
en quelque sorte tout comme limite
anakin ce qui fait potentiellement
penser ceci et que l'udc affirme que
personne ne disparaît vraiment comme
quoi ils sont toujours présents et que
nous les avons jamais oublier tout est
possible mais mais mais mais mais mais
cette phrase personne ne disparaît
vraiment possède une signification qui
pourrait être tout autre au moment où
l'udc dit cette phrase nous avons pour
visuel les restes de ce qui semble être
l'étoile de la mort
enchaînant sur le rire de palpatine
cette phrase pourrait signifier que
palpatine n'a jamais réellement disparu
et tapie dans l'ombre depuis tout ce
temps qu ils soient vivants ou une sorte
de fantôme
il ne faut pas oublier que palpatine
était à la base l'apprenti de dark les
dix lesage seigneur sith qui avait
trouvé la voie de l'immortalité
en quelque sorte palpatine l'avait trahi
il se pourrait que ce dernier connaît
son secret et expliquerait pourquoi il
est toujours vivant
néanmoins ceci pose une énorme quantité
de questions
tout d'abord pourquoi avoir utilisé ce
nom pendant les deux premiers épisodes
et non palpatine snoeck est un très
grand fan de vador et a même un rôle
similaire à palpatine dans la saga
il est sûr à 1000% que snow possède un
quelconque lien de près ou de loin avec
dark sidious peut être que depuis tout
ce temps il était à la solde de
palpatine qui dirigeait une fois de plus
les opérations depuis les ombres s'est
fortement possible je ne me rappelle
plus exactement si c'est vraiment canon
mais lors de la prélogie dans les films
la menace fantôme palpatine nous est
présenté comme le méchant principal
alors qu'en fait bas il était encore
l'apprenti entre guillemets de plailly
ce qui était à l'origine du plan de la
montée en puissance politique du futur
chancelier
nous sommes donc à peu près sur un même
cas de figure mais inversés snoeck est
mort mais palpatine reste il se peut que
sidious s'est servi de ce nom pour faire
remonter
politiquement le côté obscur au pouvoir
nok pris au jeu aurait voulu retrouver
un nouveau vador pour retracer
l'histoire et nous arrivons donc à kayes
lorraine cai lorraine tient le retour de
palpatine chamboule énormément le rôle
du nouveau suprême leader celui que nous
pensions être le méchant ultime du film
vient de se faire balayer par le retour
du seigneur sith car il est très clair
que si palpatine est réellement de
retour c'est que c'est lui le grand
méchant du film il ne peut avoir un
autre rôle
mais concernant quelle lorraine du coup
est-ce que cai lorraine était à la solde
de sidious depuis le début et non de
snacks
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
possible et pourrait expliquer le fait
qu'il ait dépassé son ancien ce dôme
être et les trahissent idiot ça
peut-être pu former qu'un îlot rennes de
son côté pour qu'ils trahissent nos
coûts mais une flopée de mystère est
encore présent car il se peut que cas il
aurait ne sait même pas que si douce est
revenu mais il est clair pour moi que si
palpatine est présent ce qu'il a tout
manipulé depuis le début et que c'est
lui qui aurait pu attirer ben du côté
obscur pour avoir un nouveau vador en
quelque sorte
néanmoins je doute encore par rapport
aux liens avec tes lorraine concernant
ray cela pourrait justifier certaines
choses déjà cela pourrait expliquer la
connexion entre elles et calais lorraine
dans star wars 8 qui à la base nous
croyons était effectué par snow que
comme affirmé par le suprême leader
déchu mais qui pourtant continue après
sa mort il se peut que ce soit au final
si diouf qui avait mis en contact les
deux protagonistes
d'ailleurs on nous rabâche depuis le
début que snow et cas il aurait ne sont
pas des sites mais des adeptes du côté
obscur et que kay lorraine est l'opposé
de ré mais si ce dernier n'est pas un
site écoeurait devienne une véritable
jedi dans le neuf le fait qu'elle
devienne une g die serait donc
illégitime en quelque sorte
il se peut que ray existe et devienne
une jedi car sidious un véritable site
est toujours en vie une jedi face aux
derniers véritables sites sidious est
l'ennemi ultime de star wars
il est très intelligent et c'est un très
grand manipulateur
le taux de dangerosité est à son point
maximum je suis très curieux de voir ce
que jj abrams a prévu pour le seigneur
sith nos héros vont devoir redoubler
d'efforts surtout ray cette analyse
était un peu différente de d'habitude et
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu
je suis très très surpris du retour de
sidious et j'arrive toujours pas à
comprendre son retour bien que le côté
marketing joue beaucoup
j'attends de voir mais je ne vous cache
pas que je suis tout de même hype
je veux savoir n'hésitez pas à me dire
ce que vous avez pensé de ce trailer
dans les commentaires et si vous
souhaitez que l'on revienne dessus en
vidéo prochainement
si tu veux me soutenir tu peux me
laisser un gros pouce bleus t'abonner
regarder quelques pubs sur un type ou me
suivre sur twitter
bref c'était votre dévoué argot rock et
que le leinster soit avec vous
[Musique]